right goats in a bad way time it can't
be tom brady this week because he didn't
play he's been on it a couple of times
this year chris give me the trivia
question we'll see who's the goat uh
possibly me if i get it wrong okay well
your favorite wide receiver in football
justin jefferson on your favorite team
with your favorite quarterback and the
favorite colors and their favorite horn
justin jefferson is the fifth rookie to
get a thousand receiving yards in 12
games there's four others
give me one or two and we'll we'll we'll
let you go
otto beckham jr only played 12 games as
a rookie and he got to a thousand yards
is he one of them i i don't know the
answer yet but i would say yes
um i i feel like randy moss is a trap
um
i'll take it i'll take it they jumped
they're gone all right
kristin what are you doing back there
kristen oh thank you man
it's matt casey he's a jets fan he
called it all out blitz on uh the game
was over he called the ll blitz and hit
the button good job yep
ankle and bolton and marcus colston or
the other man i'm looking ahead i
wouldn't have thought of those anquan
bolden and marcus colston yeah that
that's that's uh good good names from
the past there all right go ahead all
right you're the first pick i really
thought randy moss was a trap okay uh
first pick for me mm-hmm
i gotta start with greg i'll be what of
course i gotta start with greg williams
i have the list in front of me it's like
gee who do i go first i mean it's rare
for me to have the full menu at my
disposal but yeah the steak this week
the 30-ounce porterhouse is greg
williams and the idiocy that caused the
jets to blow their opportunity to get
what likely would be their only win of
the season and he got fired for it the
next day we've had plenty of goats in a
bad way over the past couple of years no
one got fired the next day he did he's
the goat of the year chris uh i mean yes
that was the easy first pick there's no
doubt about that go to the year uh might
be the go to the decade right now with
the way that looks so i'm with you there
no doubt i'm gonna go down to mike
thomas and the bengals dolphins game i
mean to me what he did you know those
cheap shots listed i can deal with it
once and even though the first time it
looked a little egregious you know to do
it a second time
and just take a shot at a guy when he's
totally unprotected like that and just
go full speed at him you know the thing
i said like i told you too i didn't like
after the first time i felt like they
were almost happy on the cincinnati
sideline that it happened and they were
telling him good job and doing all that
wasn't a good look wasn't a good look
for the bangles and
no matter what you think i mean
i know it's football
but man that's just cheap shot you can
ruin guys careers doing stuff like that
that to me had no place in the game um
him head hunting defenseless punt
returners does not make me think you're
tough or anything like that so to me
that would be my first pick of the go to
the week
yeah and that's a good one anytime
someone crosses the boundaries like that
they deserve the negative recognition
and in that same vein this one was odd
to me i saw the report yesterday
afternoon from nfl media that not one
but two players have been suspended for
stepping on opponents nobody ever gets
suspended other than in dominic and sue
for stepping on an opponent he got
suspended once and it was overturned
when he accidentally stepped on the
lower leg of aaron rodgers the same
lower leg that had had a calf muscle
injury earlier that year he claimed that
it was cold that day at lambeau field
and his feet were numb he didn't know
where he was stepping he did avoid the
suspension he stepped on evan dietrich
smith thanksgiving day 2011 and got
suspended for that but both sean
williams and the bengals and taylor tart
of the titans suspended one game for
stepping on an opponent something that
never happened so whatever they did and
the eye in the sky doesn't lie they
deserve to get suspended and maybe they
get it overturned but it at least got
the attention of the nfl so uh don't
step on opponents folks come on we have
an uh an enhanced and unprecedented
sensitivity to player health and safety
in the nfl which is a good thing any of
this stuff that would have flown in the
70s 80s 90s doesn't fly anymore and when
you do it you get called out for it yeah
yeah i mean there's there's no you know
excuse for that kind of crap and you
should get called out for it i mean
that's horrible who who were the who
were the two guys i missed the the names
who who were the both guys sean williams
sean williams and the bengals and taylor
tart of the titans both suspended one
week for stepping on an opponent wow
okay i knew the sean williams one i did
not know the titans players that's a
good one all right i'll take that that
crap's got to go it's just so stupid and
amateur that's like high school crap um
i'm pretty sure i got to go with nick
martin here the set you know i'm a
little tentative too here because i
haven't watched that film and i'm not
sure nick martin was healthy for that
game right that was him that snapped the
ball at the end of uh so texan center
i'm gonna play it safe for right now i'm
pretty sure it was nick martin maybe
matt casey or pete demolitis can check
just to make sure but it always helps to
make sure you know who the goat is
before you put the horns on you know i
couldn't pull up the film and watch it
real quick but i i that to me just that
moment the texans being inside the five
yard line nick martin he was there i'm
being confirmation in my ear um but it's
desean watson i mean once he gets inside
the five or ten it's almost like oh no
he's gonna score a touchdown this is
deshaun watson i mean they they had it
there to win the football game and upset
the indianapolis colts watson's so
phenomenal to have that bad snap and
that moment i mean it kind of wraps up
the whole texans football season in a
nutshell right there but
i got to give nick martin the go to the
week as good a player as he is that was
that was a bad one right there
and now i'm torn i'm thinking about
going dan bailey because he missed two
extra points and a 51-yard field goal
which
it's not a chip shot but it's not like a
51-yard field goal used to be i mean
that game should not have gone to
overtime and it was funny how the
vikings drove it as close to the goal
line as they could so he couldn't miss
the game-winner when they had the chance
to walk off but i'll go with the 49ers
defensive back specifically the 49ers
corners um jason verrette and richard
sherman
it's the most recent we saw it last
night and it it it just and and look
maybe it was a testament to the skill of
the bill's offense but it just was not a
good look and uh
again it's a far cry from last year when
you have a great pass rush and you don't
get tested the way they got tested last
night but they got exposed last night
and it was ugly yeah uh definitely did
you know i thought you might go there i
was i was probably gonna take richard
sherman was my next pick you know just
some of the things he did last night
giving up a few big plays it was a tough
night tough night good weapons and you
know our boy blue was and fuego i mean
he talked about it the ball just felt
really good in his hand and uh man
that was pretty special i think that
solidifies him as one of the best
quarterbacks in football there's no
doubt about that all right
i mean
i i
i don't know have we picked this have i
picked this every week of the whole year
but i'm gonna do it again
um
charger special teams okay
chargers ordinary teams i don't know
what the hell to say anymore but i i
just i gotta say it i didn't want to
pick it just because i was like i'm so
sick of picking it but to lose 45 to
nothing okay that's one thing so it's
like the organization the special teams
anthony lynn the special teams coach
that got relegated to another assistant
position two weeks ago i mean disaster
but holy crap i mean i don't know what
else to say block field goal touchdown
punt return touchdown can't line up and
punt formations we talked about that
yesterday there was five punts in the
game three of them were messed up before
the snap even happened because the
chargers couldn't get the right people
on the field i mean that that to me is
just mind-blowing so um as much as i
like anthony lynn and stuff that that
one's just that's a bad one the charger
special team just a disaster
and it was reported yesterday in
multiple places that the chargers aren't
going to make a decision on anthony lynn
until the season ends
it feels like it's moving in the
direction it does coaching change when
you have a great quarterback like justin
herbert and and you're losing so many of
these games with self-inflicted wounds
it just it's just
it's it's yeah it's hard to survive that
it's got to change it's a shame because
we both really like anthony lynn but at
some point you just have to make a
change
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports